all right McDonald's rejects Burger
Kings Makua verse done what Anna so
Burger King wanted to be a super nice
dude about it and decided to approach
McDonald's to make a mcwhopper Burger
King proposed a day of peace I did not
know they're at war mcdonald's quickly
rejected the idea by Wednesday morning
that's a sad rejection hurts no matter
who you are even if we ate the Burger
King I think it's an extra line and mash
these things up so what we're gonna do
today is we're gonna take a Big Mac and
we're going to take a whopper and we're
gonna mush them together make the
mcwhopper that we were supposed to have
so you've got your whopper here which
has that perfect char-broil taste you
know they're famous for the grill marks
the ideal thing you want to do here is
make sure you don't have too much bread
in ones place and too much meat in one
place you have to get it nice and even
I'm gonna keep the the middle bun
just cuz that's what makes a Big Mac Big
Mac and then you've got this cute these
cute little friend right here
we'll check this apart okay it's been
mcwhopper
I really hope I don't poop my pants oh
man
Lord Jesus I'm sorry for destroying this
vessel you have created this is what we
could have had McDonald's you ruined
this for us
here we go no oh oh God
why is it a real thing tastes like carbs
love it messy but delicious it's
probably a lot of calories but hey
you're getting double the veggies so I
think about is really drunk I would eat
this well if you like drop this off a
roof onto a person's head I really
actually think you could do some damage
like four pounds this is a win right
here